Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number which
you can call any time.
That number is 2192.
David P, here is a caller who has called in
after he figured out I am not a Christian
and he has some choice words for me, I will
tell you that.
Speaker 5: Huh?
Hi, David.
Yeah, I was just watching your mouth on this
TV here.
And you were saying that the protesters.
Speaker 1: The protesters?
Yes.
Speaker 5: Were outside of the Donald Trump
building when they were outside of the courthouse.
You don't even.
Speaker 1: Well, there were different videos
and some they were in one place and some they
were in the other.
Speaker 5: Well, you know what I've done figured
out because you admitted yourself you're not
a Christian.
That's true.
And you know what that makes me so happy to
hear?
Because there is a God, there is a Jesus,
there is a holy Spirit, and Satan is going
to be coming here saint in real sin, pretending
to be Jesus.
Hmm.
And little waste of firearms like you are
going to follow.
I hope so.
I want you to follow that Jesus all the way
to the lake of fire right along with Donald
Trump.
Speaker 1: Okay, well, very, very powerful
declaration.
And be aware.
Satan will come back pretending to be Jesus
very, very soon.
Certainly something to be scared of.
On the bonus show today, we are going to talk
about the truth of Manhattan District Attorney
Alvin Bragg's alleged ties to billionaire
George Soros.
What are the ties?
Do they exist?
Are they what Republicans claim them to be?
We will explore.
Secondly, Disneyworld.
After everything that happened in Florida
with Ron DeSantis, they don't say gay bill
taking away Disney's rights there in that
neighborhood district that they have, after
all of it is said and done.
Disney is hosting a major summit on gay rights.
They seem really intimidated by DeSantis,
guys.
We'll talk about that.
And lastly, the Fed again raised interest
rates yesterday, this time by 25 basis points,
despite the stress hitting the banking system.
But in a context where we are being led to
believe that the Fed's work is seemingly close
to done in this cycle of interest rate increases.
Where are we?
What do we expect?
What is the impact of raising versus lowering
the federal funds rate?
We're going to go over all of it, my friends,
on today's bonus show.
Sign up for membership at join Pacman dot
com.
You will get instant access to the bonus show.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that makes
money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Alex Jones despises the bonus show,
but actual members love it.
You can sign up at join packman dot com.
You can use the coupon code indict to save
yourself significantly off of the cost of
membership.
We will see you then.
And then we'll be back tomorrow with the Friday
show.